and um shirk is one of the things that
we don't like however it does not mean
just because I dislike it
means that I have a problem with you
celebrating it do you get it and I think
it should be fair because if Muslims
have the right to celebrate eat why
should you in your own country not be
not be allowed to celebrate Christmas
[Music]
[Music]
my dear friends I'm here with Santa
Claus I'm not talking about him I'm
talking about this one here and so
there's there's a big misconception
obviously that's going around and I was
speaking to a lady here regarding this
issue as well that there is
misconception that we as Muslims that
Easter bothers us you know when we go to
Tesco's and we see those chocolates
besides wanting to eat it that it really
really offends us that for example when
there's Christmas carols you are when
there's a Christmas tree here or when
there's Santa Claus you are that it
really really bothers us to be honest
Santa Claus doesn't have a direct link
with because they say Christmas is based
upon Jesus's birth right but I don't
know how Santa Claus comes into that
yeah it doesn't I don't know he's just
busy looking after his deers flying
around giving gifts around here so thank
you very much for that thank you thank
you so yeah I just wanted to say like
this big misconception it's it's a lie
you know and I was speaking to this lady
as well over here that um she was I
think 20 years ago yeah yeah 20 years
ago what happened exactly
um my children had just started Primary
School yeah in Hackney yeah and
um they they the school said no there's
going to be no Nativity Play the
Christmas holidays we're going to call
them winter break yeah and I said why is
this and they said because we don't want
to offend the Muslim Community
um
so I went and asked the Muslim parents
yeah and none of them were offended by
it they all thought it was a little
ridiculous without canceling it yeah
yeah and especially as the school were
always we all the other cultures
celebrations would work knowledge but
they were too scared to acknowledge
Christmas because they didn't want to
offend the Muslims but the Muslims
weren't offended because I asked them
and so I went back to the staff and I
said they're not offended they say oh no
no we still can't do it and that was 20
years ago and I wish I knew now what I
knew then I should have started a
petition I should have done more about
it got all the most important yeah yeah
but they canceled Christmas and because
the left left wing which is very happy
very lovely Borough they were being
offended on the muslim's behalf and it
was unnecessary yeah you're right you
know it's it's exactly of course it's a
divide exactly exactly this is exactly
it's like they don't want to cause
divide but they are causing a divide you
know so as a Muslim I'm an orthodox
Muslim you know I don't call my religion
I don't you know I believe Islam in
every single text that he has yeah so I
can tell you very clearly we do not
celebrate Christmas however we are not
offended by you celebrating Christmas
you're singing the Christmas carols
whatever you it involves it doesn't
bother us I'm telling you to your face
I'm not even sure of course some people
say oh he's doing Takia Tokyo is not
even part I don't even know what Tokyo
is yeah this is a certain group uh in
Islam they use it and that's even them
in context that is if your life is in
danger if somebody comes and says I'm
going to kill you then renounce your
religion even then that's when you use
it yeah but we don't want to have Takia
so the issue is I'm being very Brown you
I do not have no problem yeah because we
came you know Amy there was a lady she
came once and she had bacon in her hand
and she was waving in her face and and I
felt like like you know I'm not like a
vampire even garlic oh no not the bacon
you know the thing is it's the bacon
doesn't offend us these things we just
because we don't we're not allowed to
eat it doesn't mean we think the
animal's evil yeah we don't hold that
animals evil now Christmas obviously if
that if now it's become like you know it
looks like a cultural thing did you get
it so the thing is it's like it's not
like the celebration of the birth of
Jesus to us it's a big sin in Islam it's
a major sin in Islam and um shik is one
of the things that we don't like however
it does not mean just because I dislike
it
it means that I have a problem with you
celebrating it you get it and I think it
should be fair because if Muslims have
the right to celebrate eat why should
you in your own country not be not be
allowed to celebrate Christmas do you
get it so I want to get this yeah surely
I mean there's been a few like a couple
of Christmas massacres there's one
recently I think was it in France yes
yes there was one in France why was the
Muslim guy I mean what was his
denomination why was he behaving like
that okay so now the thing is with these
people I think so I heard he had a
Muslim name but I don't know his
intentions I think he was influenced by
Isis yeah now the thing is with these
people most of them you see is that
they're young most of them are young and
naive yeah so the prophet peace be upon
him when he lived with the Christians
and the Jews he said that there was
covenants that were made yeah he said
your cross your place of worship yeah
your laws your regulations your
livelihood whatever it may be nobody can
harm you guys okay because that's your
religious beliefs so if we had a problem
if the prophet had a problem yeah so we
want to look at their T what these guys
are doing and what the prophet did did
they put of it when he was living with
the Christians and the Jews when he
wasn't in power and when he was in power
yet okay when the Sharia was in power
okay the Sharia law that everybody talks
about when the Muslims were in power
they never never forced or oppressed the
Christians of the Jews to go so so
imagine are we empowering our other
Muslims in power
no there isn't so if we was in power and
we did not force the Christians and the
Jews to our way of life or destroy the
cross for their Christmas what do you
think why would we do it when we don't
have power when we was at our Peak so
these people who follow they're a bunch
of
young naive I guarantee you they follow
it let me tell you something let me tell
you something let me tell you something
here most of these people they are
brainwashed yeah because if you go to
the experts look let me show you some
something here if you go to the experts
who have deal dealt with this matter you
will see some shocking statements and
let me show you something very
interesting
uh let me see actually one second
sometimes I don't have internet
because I want to go to
the experts in this field in 2010 a
Pakistani born U.S citizen Faisal was
arrested for attempting a terrorist
attack yeah in Times Square his attempt
was to carry out a car bomb and had it
it didn't go off thank God if it went
off it would have killed hundreds of
people yeah during his trial they asked
him
why did you want to kill civilians
including children this is what he said
he said well the drones drones that hit
in Afghanistan and Iraq they don't see
children they don't see anybody they
kill women children everybody they kill
Muslims yeah now if you go to for
example he wasn't the only person here
there was a guy called Farouk Abdul
muttalib he was the called the underwear
bomber yeah okay
there was another guy called zokar
Boston what happened in New York
all of them if you go they blame foreign
policy yeah okay
now what I want to mention is for
example uh
that this is a former head of joint
specialist operations Commander Stanley
McChrystal he pointed out that careless
use of drone strikes caused result in
suicide bombs in Central Park so what
he's saying is we're trying to get rid
of terrorists by using drone strikes but
we're causing more terrorists yeah so
these people they have been there from
day one they are known as the khawaris
yeah that's what they refer to as and at
the time of the Prophet peace be upon
him they tried to insult the prophet
yeah they try to insult him I think they
said something they insulted him and the
companions wanted to kill them and the
prophet stopped it yeah he said don't
yeah and the prophet warned us against
them they said from this man's lineage
the man who did that to the prophet they
said there's going to come every nation
to the day of judgment they're going to
always rise up yeah and the prophet said
where if I lived at their time in every
single time sorry sorry I would destroy
them like God Almighty destroyed ads
that was a nation reason being is
because these guys are a bigger enemy to
us than anyone else because they look
like us they walk like us they talk like
us so when they carry out these attacks
what does the general non-muslims think
Islam it's these Muslims are the problem
yeah but these guys are a bigger enemy
to us and most of them two guys from
Britain went to join Isis they were
caught with dummies for Muslims dummy
dummies you know the yeah
can you imagine can you imagine they
they have no idea about the religion
most of them they probably don't even
pray yeah
all they do is emotions they're killing
our brothers and sisters in Iraq we're
going to do the same the point is where
in Islam does it teach you to do that
where in Islam it says that they do that
you retaliate back the same way
certainly not a Christmas Market as well
of course the thing is these people do
you think there's people too telling
these people yeah you should go and do
it yes Isis Isis Isis specifically and
also there's also God knows who's behind
them there's all kinds of stuff
happening in today's times that we live
in so these people are brainwashed just
as well just as much as Tommy Robinson
preaches his hate and then you have
Darren Osborne going to run and over
Muslims in frimsbury park yeah so the
thing is they they they live off each
other I believe Isis and the far right
are business partners because one when
one car is an attack they say oh look
what they've done to us you see what
they're doing to us we need to retaliate
back when they return it back you have
tomorrow to say look this is Islam this
is Isis they're trying to take over they
benefit of each other that's the reason
why I speak out against extremism be
Isis be it the far right be a Shia share
extreme just whoever they are yeah
because it's you our sister and me we're
the ones who suffer at their hands when
you're walking down the road you're
scared what some extremist Muslim is
going to kill you when I come to the
park I'm being honest I'll get that
fresh from the far right I mean I've had
awesome warnings yeah I've had somebody
go to the phone box and say that if you
don't sort out Muhammad hijab myself
we're gonna sort them out yeah we heard
the police tell us to be careful so the
thing is these people we're the ones who
suffer we're the ones who end up getting
killed while they Tommy Robinson sitting
in his nice comfy house and Andrew
choudhary yeah and Isis well they're
sipping their teeth
yes he says hello I believe
yes he said look I'm being honest I know
he has had some but sometimes he's he
exaggerates and lies a lot sadly because
he accused me of sharing his address
which he knows it wasn't me it was
another white lady who did it but that's
another story the thing is he gets These
Warnings and I'm being honest has he had
it before yes he has does he exaggerate
in life I believe he does yeah but
that's another topic that's another
issue yeah but the thing is he's doing
that but then again he's preaching hate
and he's causing innocent Muslims to get
attacked on the streets
oh of course no for example so when he
says for example oh behind me are enemy
combatant uh households yeah there's
Muslims living around there the Muslims
even around because I don't think what
I've seen of him it doesn't seem to
really you know attack Muslims per se
not only I think he does look at certain
things in the headaches no no that's
that's he attacks look he says oh I've
got no problem with the Muslims but he
does he's attacking Islam it's not it's
not just because he says oh we're not
allowed to criticize Islam yes you are
one thing that's not allowed to be
criticized is Israel that he gets funded
by he gets funded by yeah most of Israel
is the country that nobody criticizes
nobody talks against it so so but it's
it's if you think about it if there's
one kind of thing that does not be
criticized it's not Islam we don't say
Islam we say don't insult our religion
you can criticize our religion criticize
it all day all night but insulting is a
different story do you get it if I
insulted a black person or whatever I
can it's how is that criticizing do you
know what I'm trying to say so coming
back to our Point Christopher I mean
Christopher everybody shouldn't be above
criticism no you can look you can
criticize you can come and say to me why
did the prophet do this why does Islam
teach that no problem that's the reason
why we give that one I think the thing
with Tommy though background things from
Luton isn't it yeah it seems to be they
have certain problems I think there was
that young lady who won the Strictly
Come Dancing Yeah she did a little
documentary see some of that yeah when
she was in Luton and I don't think she
was getting them she was a bit shocked
she was almost in tears basically yeah
some of the the Muslim communities there
I'm not sure what denominations they
were yeah but they were they were they
weren't too friendly to her I think you
can see the documentary on YouTube no no
I just I just needed them why was it why
were they not friendly to us for what
reason well she was there was a parade
or like a March
oh is this the one where they called you
you're going to go to the fire like a
red dress yeah and they said Andrew
because you're dressed up like this or
um
yes who is this Andrew told his
followers yeah Andrew Charlie he was in
there I saw the documentary she goes
they were filming and then there's a
woman yes
[Music]
happy Christmas don't touch me yeah have
you feel the stone don't touch me
is our problem this is our problem why
does why does BBC have him on speed dial
in the video though it was there was
quite a big summer process and people
were saying you know making this kind of
disparaging comments about British
troops yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
were there as well I don't remember
no no his followers were there yeah you
see you see these guys they they hate us
they they have a problem with me I get
flipped by I get difference for Isis
yeah no decimal yes trust me I get I get
I did my five come to my house what did
I say to you that you're not radical
enough no they say I'm a disbeliever
okay why do they sell you with this
because you know why because I came here
and me and a few other brothers we
exposed icy supporters and there's
footages of it we went up to them and
said look stop your nonsense because if
their friend was the one who carried
that along the bridge itself Karen Bots
yeah we went and exposed them because
they're not knowledgeable you can see it
right alidawa uh confronts Andrew's
supporter yeah he has no clue he's
ignorant about Islam that's why I
brought my teachers
this guy uh what's his name
we confronted him reason why because we
said it's because of you because of you
we get the blame because we get attacked
why because you and your blood extreme
is not I'm not gonna use the extreme
because it has the connotation behind it
yeah with your views okay I believe
extreme is all kind of some of their
views are not particularly immersive for
are they no but this is what I'm saying
Islam is free from these people trust me
Islam is free from these people that's
why we confront them and we expose them
you know why because if they go on
Bloody carry an attack next week we can
tell the British police look we won't we
don't even know why these guys are on
the roads yeah so they believe that I'm
a disbeliever because
um that I believe that you can report
these people to the police
and they believe that no you can't
report another Muslim to the authorities
have the police been towards you okay no
problem no no please I'm fine with the
police me I'm cool I don't I don't have
no I have no criminal record you know
unlike Tommy Robinson but yeah you know
Stacy Dooley yeah yeah yeah coming back
to our thing I have no problem with your
Christmas celebrations whatever I just
want to take that misconception out
there you know and yeah sorry I know
assistant needs to go yeah yeah yeah
yeah
thank you sorry sorry
yeah
thank you have a nice day
take care